o desafio duplo adriana
boa tarde boa tarde pessoal é seja viram
que hoje algumas histórias inspiradoras
algumas reflexões sobre o papel do
indivíduo do cidadão e agora nós vamos
dar sequência tratando de desafios que
vão ligar metrópoles e meio ambiente
tanto do ponto de vista da gestão como
também da regulação e quais são então
esses desafios quais são os principais
problemas que incidem sobre a cidade
claro que a lista não é pequena então a
gente resolveu selecionar alguns deles
para tratar com vocês aqui hoje
a gente vai começar pela mudança do
clima um problema global em 2012
agentes edil aqui a rio + 20 reunindo
mais de 190 países e 60 mil pessoas
vinte anos após a eco 92 quando se
consolidou o conceito de desenvolvimento
sustentável é felizmente em 2012 mundo
não acabou como algumas teorias
equivocadamente indicavam mas é o último
relatório do ipcc
um grupo de cientistas que reúne os
principais cientistas do mundo todo que
trata de mudança do clima indica que a
atuação a interferência dos seres
humanos no sistema climático do planeta
é está ocorrendo e que a mudança do
clima por sua vez oferece riscos tanto
para a gente quanto para o meio ambiente
portanto apesar das teorias mais
catastróficas não terem se concretizado
fica claro a urgência é de que a gente
de fato se mobilize e se prepare para
essa nova realidade o que inclui as
cidades
o segundo tópico de hoje é o tópico da
mobilidade e se ainda ativa na verdade
nós acabamos de ouvir aqui é uma
história sobre uma pessoa que chama
clarice como ela tantas outras enfrentam
longe de mobilidade quem aqui que nunca
perdeu um compromisso nunca perdeu a
hora porque ficou duas ou três horas de
engarrafamento
se existe alguém aqui na platéia que
levantar um deles e assim eu nunca isso
nunca aconteceu comigo certamente um
pouquinho são as pessoas acreditaram na
verdade é todo mundo sofre como toda é a
população as empresas se preocupam claro
porque é impossível exigir produtividade
alguém que fica duas três horas no
trânsito e os governos também precisam
priorizar corretamente os investimentos
e os incentivos que tocam nessa questão
próximo tópico que a gente vai trabalhar
é o de resíduos
claro que ninguém quer ter um depósito
de lixo perto de casa mas a gente
precisa sim se preocupar com é de que
forma esses resíduos estão sendo
tratados de forma estão sendo coletados
e pra onde isso tudo vai ler hoje a
gente observa que basta chover que os
bueiros da cidade entope as ruas ao lado
então agora mais cedo estava falando das
cidades mal planejadas é existe uma
questão de manutenção que deveria ser
observadas em dúvida mas não dá também
para a gente só contar com o governo
nessa gente continuar jogando lixo nas
ruas não têm manutenção que dê conta
disso
portanto é importante a gente é entender
qual é a nossa parcela com a nossa
participação nessa equação não dá pra
continuar de braços cruzados esperando o
governo e as empresas se mobilizar ea
gente precisa entender qual é o nosso
papel como consumidores e como cidadãos
ana você estava falando sobre a rio +20
aqui
a eco 92 desde no brasil na década de 90
desde que nós vemos a rio-92 aqui
o brasil vem adotando uma postura bem
proativa em relação às mudanças do clima
uma prova disso é que mesmo sem ter
metas obrigatórias
lá no protocolo de kyoto o brasil 2009
editor a sua política nacional de
mudança de clima uma lei que prevê
diversos instrumentos e muitos deles já
estão até a funcionando
um exemplo interessante é o fundo do
clima é que apoia projetos
há pesquisas estudos e também uma boa
parte desse fundo vai pra financiar
empreendimentos que tenham um impacto
positivo na questão climática
agora alguns instrumentos ainda não
saíram do papel um exemplo nós podemos
dar aqui é o mercado brasileiro de
emissões ou seja o brasil prevê esse
mercado na política nacional
esse mercado teria uma contribuição
muito relevante é principalmente alguns
setores chaves para a questão climática
mas ele ainda não saiu do papel
mas se tem razão no caso de mudança do
clima a gente já tem um aparato
regulatório é importante robusto no país
mas é preciso ainda assim tem uma
sinalização clara de que rumos do país
que a tomar para que as empresas possam
internalizar essa nova variável no seu
planejamento
do ponto de vista das cidades é
importante entender qual o impacto que a
mudança do clima vai trazer e claro isso
varia de uma cidade para a outra mas
também entender de que forma que isso é
toca na população que mora necessidade
que é o que a gente chama de
vulnerabilidade
no caso do rio de janeiro por ser uma
cidade costeira a gente se preocupe
imediatamente com a questão da elevação
do nível do mar mas outras questões como
o impacto sobre agricultura
deslizamentos de terra também têm que
ser observadas na verdade só para
lembrar se nós fomos andar alguns anos
pra trás
tivemos duas tragédias né em santa
catarina em 2009 e outra na região
serrana do rio de janeiro em 2011
e como nós vimos mais cedo né na
palestra do pr
não dá pra ficar culpando as chuvas na
verdade é isso aí e se a gente olhar o
caso de são paulo por exemplo é as
previsões indicam a possibilidade de um
aumento do dia de do número de dias com
chuvas intensas
tudo bem hoje até pode soar como boa
notícia mas o fato é que decide se a
gente não se planejar e não internalizar
este é a possibilidade de ter esse novo
cenário essa nova realidade é possível
que a gente encara também um futuro
próximo com aumento de enchentes e de
alagamentos
bom é isso nos traz para a questão da
mobilidade né
voltando a são paulo hoje a gente
observa
é o inventário de emissão de gases de
efeito estufa da cidade cerca de 50% das
emissões de dióxido de carbono provém do
uso de transportes em particular o
rodoviário
hoje é rio e são paulo já podem ser
consideradas as cidades mais
engarrafadas das américas o que pode ser
feito a respeito
as empresas já começam a implementar
algumas medidas como instituir home
office você passar talvez trabalhar um
dia ou dois em casa durante a semana o
horário diferenciado de trabalho para
evitar que as pessoas fiquem muito tempo
no trânsito mas ainda claro não é
suficiente é fala se muito da da
introdução de veículos híbridos veículos
elétricos
hoje no brasil um veículo elétrico custa
cerca de 200 mil reais
a gente não tem na infraestrutura capaz
de é suportar esse tipo de veículo
mas além disso mesmo a introdução desses
veículos se fosse o caso a gente adotar
como com medida também deveria estar
aliado a outras medidas para que a gente
possa assim ter uma mobilidade mais
sustentável ou seja a solução para o
transporte tem que ser também pensada em
conjunto com a questão da habitação que
novamente nos remete ao tema cidades
metrópoles é os pontos de integração
modal que hoje nos fazem repensar de
certo modo aquele espaço urbano uso
daquele espaço urbano poderiam servir
pra gente ofertar serviços e comércio
a gente é importante ofertar à população
um transporte público de qualidade com
conforto trazer informação em tempo real
e sobretudo que esse transporte tem uma
fiscalização e operacionalização mais
adequada é anã você sabe que isso são
paulo sua cidade mais engarrafada das
américas na segundo estudo recente mas
várias metrópoles no brasil enfrentam
questões sérias mobilidade então
procurando né começar a planejar uma
nova política de mobilidade o brasil
ditou uma lei que traz à nossa política
nacional de mobilidade urbana e bom
claro né senhor acha que para o advogado
vai ficar muito falando muito sobre as
leis mas vou falar apenas um
aspectos que são os principais né por
exemplo nessa lei fica muito clara a
prioridade que vai ser dada ao
transporte coletivo em detrimento do
transporte individual é aquela pessoa
que sair com o automóvel para ir para o
trabalho para ir a algum compromisso e
como isso vai ser feito
bom essa lei traz alguns instrumentos
interessantes como por exemplo né a
possibilidade de você restringir o
tráfego de veículos em determinados
locais e horários que são os chamados
rodízio jinan que já ocorre em algumas
cidades como são paulo também mas não só
isso né
uma política não é também possível de
sobretaxada em cima de alguns modos de
transporte da cobrança de pedágios em
determinadas áreas da cidade ou seja
pode ser que no futuro nós temos que
pagar um pedágio para entrar com o carro
aqui no centro do rio de janeiro ou de
outra cidade dentro do brasil e traz
também uma coisa que é muito
interessante que a política de
estacionamentos
olha se o poder público quer
desestimular o uso do automóvel tem uma
forma muito simples é só acabar com as
vagas
muitas vezes você vai sair de casa pega
a chave do carro e aí pensa onde vou
parar o carro e muitas vezes com
inteligência você deixa a chave pega um
táxi
você sabe que vai rodar não vai achar
vaga ou vai achar uma vaga com um preço
astronômico né então onde o poder
público quiser incentivar o uso do
automóvel permite o estacionamento de
onde foi o caso de desistimula ele
simplesmente vai fazer o quê diminuir
esses espaços com estacionamentos aliás
alguém que veio de carro
alguém veio porque interessante em que
quase lhe levantou a mão legal agora ou
querem levantar a mão
eu não vi quase ninguém no tamanho gente
não eu acho bacana que é uma opção
sustentável vieram de transporte
coletivo a maioria é muito legal
ela está falando dos do plano de
mobilidade urbana a gente também
comentou antes sobre as metas de redução
de emissão de gases efeito estufa
no caso de resíduos a gente observa que
a política nacional de resíduos sólidos
havia instituído que para o dia 2 de
agosto de 2014 há dez dias atrás não
poderia mais haver lixões a céu aberto
no país como um todo então nós vamos
dizer que fim levou essa meta mas basta
a gente olhar para algumas estatísticas
hoje 40% de tudo que é gerado todos os
resíduos que são geradas apenas 40% é
segue para uma destinação adequada
isso faz com que a gente tenha uma perda
de cerca de 8 bilhões de reais por ano
com o material que deixa de ser
reciclado
claro que a gente já está muito avançado
em algumas questões como é o caso das
latinhas de alumínio
mas de tudo que é coletado corretamente
tudo que que é coletado menos de 2% são
é seguem para a separação e para a
reciclagem portanto é importante é
importante é colocar mais medidas que
incentivem o reuso a reciclagem
condições mais dignas de trabalho para
os catadores e claro uma geração menor
de resíduos é nisso que a gente quer
chegar
então é bom até para quem não percebeu a
coincidência de sobrenomes o pedro meu
primo me ver em casa porque tenho pra
gente preparar um pouquinho essa
conversa de hoje e por acaso não foi
possível a gente cozinhar porque o botão
do fogão do meu fogão a quebrou também o
cara pra consertar foi não esquece joga
fora contra o outro
afinal é possível achar outro cara
consegui consertar enfim mas o fato é
que as coisas não são feitas para durar
são feitas para você jogar fora voltar
ao mercado e encontrar de novo que é o
que a gente chama de obsolescência
programada pois é comigo esse ano
aconteceu a mesma coisa né eu consegui
consertar um microondas e ele está lá
firme e forte
agora imaginem
né se eu ea ana simplesmente tivesse
jogado fora
o fogão e microondas a quantidade de
resíduos totalmente desnecessários que
nós teríamos jogado no ambiente bom
a questão do lixo também é objeto de uma
política específica a política nacional
de resíduos sólidos
essa lei traz duas coisas muito
interessantes
a primeira delas é que ela estabelece a
responsabilidade compartilhada não só os
fabricantes mas os fabricantes
comerciantes importadores do poder
público e de nós que num determinado
momento dessa cadeia somos consumidores
mas após continuamos sendo cidadãos
então a lei estabelece além disso a
chamada logística reversa que seria isso
é o caminho inverso já que o produto tem
toda uma logística tem todo um caminho
pra vir da produção até o nosso consumo
o que sobra desse consumo deve voltar o
setor produtivo para que ele consiga na
e utilizar reaproveitar reciclar e se
nada disso for possível que ele possa
dar uma destinação adequada a esses
resíduos sem dúvida e não dá pra gente
continuar também falando de resíduos se
a gente não falar pelo menos um
pouquinho do que contribui para a
geração desses resíduos na e no caso de
compras de consumo de novo é um tema que
nos remete à atuação do poder público do
setor privado e da gente e sobretudo nos
faz pensar um pouco sobre o papel da
sociedade o comportamento do consumidor
quando os governos as empresas
internalizam no seu processo de compras
o critério da sustentabilidade
eles estão assumindo um papel importante
não só no sentido de dar um bom exemplo
é permear esse conceito pela sua cadeia
de fornecedores e mostrar para os
indivíduos que trabalham nas empresas
que vale a pena
há pouco tempo foi lançado o manual de
compras é e que nos mostra que a
importância de se olhar para o ciclo de
vida do produto e para a gente analisar
que o impacto
tal do produto que a gente consome que
depois a gente descarta não se restringe
apenas a essas etapas etapa do consumo
sobretudo etapa do descarte mas ela deve
se observar dela ela permeia toda a
cadeia de produção daquele produto
passando desde as leis da extração de
matéria-prima processo de produção é
transporte consumo depois disposição
final
portanto isto tem que ser observado isso
faz com que a gente consiga internalizar
essa eternidade ambiental e faz também
com que o próprio consumidor possa se
enxergar como ela dentro dessa cadeia ou
seja a gente compra porque a gente gera
demanda e depois consumir a gente também
gera esse resíduos também a nossa
responsabilidade é verdade ou seja
existe um manual existe informação
existe inclusive uma lei que determina
que o poder público nas suas aquisições
ou seja na compra de produtos ou na
contratação de serviços que ele leva em
conta sempre que possível o critério da
sustentabilidade
então por exemplo ao adquirir um produto
em grande escala o poder público levar
em conta o ciclo de vida dos produtos só
que isso essa lei ela não está sendo tão
aplicada como poderia
pois é hoje apesar de o governo já
internalizar o critério da
sustentabilidade é nas suas contas
apenas 0,1 por cento das compras do
governo de fato prioriza essa questão
agora a pergunta que fica é que a gente
hoje mais cedo é o que acho que tava
comentando aqui existem duas categorias
de pessoas que consideram que os
recursos são finitos nós economistas e
os loucos
eu sou economista meu psiquiatra e
psicanalista minha psicóloga então
talvez eu esteja aqui pagando um pouco
difícil os pecados mas o que a gente
pode fazer é bom ter um plano para
advogado
ora gente o que nós podemos fazer o que
nós devemos fazer não é bom
muita coisa né não somos apenas sujeitos
passivos nessa história ao contrário né
nós temos que nós temos que adotar e
podemos adotar
é votar na tatá e adotar atitudes pró
ativas em todos esses campos então por
exemplo no que se refere à compras
não dá pra ficar apenas comprando
produtos puro impulso né
olhando para o preço para a aparência né
nós temos que pensar verdadeiramente
questões ambientais e mais do que isso
nós temos que pensar várias vezes antes
de comprar um produto se nós podemos
ainda consertar o que ainda existe por
exemplo no que se refere à a mobilidade
está voltando a resíduos né
nós somos a ponta inversa da cadeia nós
somos a ponta da logística reversa não
dá pra ficar esperando que o poder
público a coleta seletiva que as
empresas vão bater na nossa porta nós
temos que de alguma forma contribuir
para que isso aconteça seja é pedindo
por síndico do prédio é seja entrando em
contato com a companhia que recolhe o
lixo né
nós temos que pensar em gerar menos
resíduos como por exemplo consertando
algumas coisas
no caso de mobilidade claro a gente pode
pensar institui carona solidária seja no
prédio onde a gente mora nos condomínios
no trabalho e sobretudo quando possível
utilizar transporte público em
detrimento do privada
na verdade podemos em algumas situações
até caminhar pedalar ou seja fazer um
exercício tem um estilo de vida mais
saudável até perdeu o equilíbrio na
verdade
bom agora se você ainda acredita que a
mudança do clima é esse bicho de sete
cabeças essa coisa inalcançável que você
nada pode fazer né pra contribuir para
um clima melhor para uma questão
climática melhor no futuro então nós
temos que pensar que tudo isso todos
esses hábitos insustentáveis neto dessa
forma sustentável que nós temos adotado
até aqui e aí falando governos empresas
e pessoas né tudo isso também né
consiste tudo isso incorpora a nossa
pegada climática então mudar esses
hábitos né não só de consumo
mas outros se nós vimos aqui tudo isso
vai contribuir para um clima melhor no
futuro em todos os sentidos
então ou seja não adianta você esperar
que uma simples lei no papel
mude a realidade nós ea todos nós temos
que ser agentes multiplicadores né
nós temos que ser agentes dessa mudança
para que pessoas com uma cultura
sustentável possam botar em prática leis
que cuidam do meio ambiente
essa é a mensagem que a gente queria
deixar com vocês aqui hoje pessoal que
juntos
governos empresas e cidadãos podem sim
buscar soluções mais efetivas para que a
gente possa morar em cidades mais
sustentáveis
obrigado obrigado